hardship but rather Allah has
made true faith beloved to you
and he has adorned it in your
heart. And he has made
despicable to you in your
hearts. Disbelief. And major
sin and all
obedience in general. Those
with such descriptions are
truly the ones who are
enlightened.
Those who are enlightened have
been chosen and been endowed
with such enlightenment.
Ultimately as a
grace from Allah and as a
blessing from Allah. And Allah
is all knowing, all wise. Allah
then goes into the the next two
verses which basically today we
just discussed some
introductory ideas Upon which
we're going to or based which
we are going to understand the
next two verses. Which he says
subhanahu wa ta'ala and into
and if two sides of the
believers
dispute and fight Then we are
too
we are then
try to harmonize between the
two groups and if one of those
two groups transgresses against
the other, then fight
collectively against the
transgressing group until they
return to the command of Allah,
to the will of Allah. And if,
and when they return, to the
command of Allah, then
harmonize between the two
groups. With justice and
precision. Indeed, Allah does
love those who are constantly
just and fair.
Truly it is the believers who
are brothers, the believers,
our true brothers. So,
harmonize and spread harmony
between your brothers and
observe the reverence of Allah
in order that you may be shown
mercy. So, here Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
commands us
be fair, to be just
be equal
between two groups of
believers. And Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala informs us that he
loves those who are fair, those
who are just. This fairness has
to be With regards to the
judgment of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, irrespective of our
relationship with either a side
of this disagreement.
Whether
we are close to the one
who is oppressing or we are at
odds with the one who is being
oppressed We are to judge
we are to judge upon insight
with the judgment of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The
judgement of Allah true justice
and true fairness.
And so, the true scales of
justice are those scales which
are
calibrated to the judgment and
will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
As communicated to us in the
Quran and in the authentic
sunnah of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]